what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios could
possibly be doing something that fans
really did not expect them to do now
this is something that has kind of been
in the back of people's minds of
something that Marvel Studios could do
especially right now because it could
offer a solution to a so-called problem
that Marvel Studios is having right now
according to some people in the fandom
and what is being discussed right now is
the possibility of Marvel rebooting the
Marvel Cinematic Universe resetting it
starting over whatever you want to call
it but essentially they would be going
back to phase one and essentially that
would kind of erase everything that
we've seen so far which in turn might
really upset some fans however I do
believe that there are multiple ways to
reboot the MCU and still keep everything
that the MCU has previously done we're
gonna talk about what these ways are but
right away go ahead and let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below what are your initial reactions to
hearing that the MCU might be rebooted
or completely reset or even just a soft
reset what are your thoughts on that do
you think this would be a good idea or
not and let us know if you'd be upset if
they erased phases one through three if
they erased everything that happened
with Iron Man and Captain America and
Thor and the Hulk Etc would this upset
you or would you be excited for a new
universe or both let us know down below
and if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news so since Marvel Studios
is already doing seek rewards and since
they've already begun to talk about
incursions in the MCU the thought of
Marvel Studios using incursions and the
secret War storyline to reset the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has been on people's
minds because this makes sense and it
makes sense for multiple reasons
especially if you consider kind of the
state of Marvel Studios right now but
right now let's fast forward to the end
of Avengers Secret Wars we know that the
events leading up to Secret Wars
including Avengers Kang Dynasty will
start to show us incursions actually
happening in the Multiverse this means
worlds are going to get destroyed
universes are going to get destroyed we
saw this a little bit in Multiverse of
Madness but when Doctor Strange was
speaking to the Illuminati they said you
are friend Dr Steven strange caused an
incursion therefore causing the death of
billions of people and we are going to
start to see more of this in fact CLIA
told Doctor Strange in the post-credits
scene of Multiverse of Madness that he
caused another one so incursions are
going to start happening and they're
going to start happening pretty
frequently as we build up to Secret Wars
we also know that Kang is most likely
going to win at first in Kang Dynasty
and this will most likely result in the
destruction of the Multiverse so fast
forward to the end of Avengers Secret
Wars where the Avengers finally do win
what do they do then well in the comics
the Fantastic Four restore the multi
diverse but of course as we know Marvel
Studios never exactly copies a story
from the comics rather they take
inspiration from the stories and take
cool little Easter eggs and put them in
the movies they never adapt story page
for page as they shouldn't because we
would know everything that's gonna
happen however it is safe to assume that
the entire Multiverse isn't going to
remain destroyed as we go into phase
seven the Multiverse in some part will
be restored now they could restore the
entire thing back to how it was
originally before the events of Secret
Wars and Kang Dynasty happened or they
could partially restore it only able to
restore part of it and continue on from
there which will no doubt cause some
pretty big changes moving forward in
Phase seven or the final option would be
to Simply move forward from a destroyed
Multiverse and expand different
timelines and basically have a new
Multiverse Sprout up and be created now
the first option that would be
everything goes back to pretty much
normal the events of Iron Man Thor
Captain America basically phase one
through phase 6 all did happen they
happened in the main timeline and we
continue on in the main timeline nothing
gets reset we just move forward the
history of everything Remains the Same
however with the other options it does
give Marvel Studios a chance to Simply
reset the universe and from there start
from scratch and start from a phase one
not a phase seven and there could be a
lot of reasons why Marvel Studios would
want to do this and according to a new
report from Insider can we get some
toast they state that this is actually
very likely to happen can we get some
toast tweeted yesterday the writings on
the wall Avengers Secret Wars is very
likely setting up a soft reboot to the
entire MCU kind of like what the flash
did for the DCU it'll be a send-off for
not only the entirety of the fox verse
but the MCU that we've all grown to love
and the aftermath will be an all new all
different MCU now let me explain what
this tweet means so you can fully
understand what it means for the MCU The
Flash movie if you did not see it did
reset the flash Universe now right now
the DC Universe is resetting James Gunn
and Peter saffron are rebooting it it
will no longer be the universe where
Henry Cavill is Superman Gal Gadot was
one ruleman although that has been quite
a mess lately but we know that a new
Superman is coming in a new Batman is
coming in the Green Lantern is coming in
they are resetting the universe and they
did this softly with the Flash and the
Flash before the events of the time
traveling and Multiverse traveling took
place everything was normal Gal Gadot
was there as Wonder Woman Henry Cavill
was there Superman and Ben Affleck was
Batman however after he came back from
undoing basically all the destruction
that he caused there was still a change
to the universe when he got to the end
and this is a spoiler alert for the
flash if you don't want any spoilers
mute this for about 10 seconds but in
the final scene there was a new Batman
of that Batman was George Clooney so
basically what this showed them was that
hey yeah you went back in time and you
messed with the Multiverse and you tried
to undo it but essentially you couldn't
so now the the universe that you're in
is different this is exactly what it
sounds like they're going to be doing
for the MCU so it's one of those
scenarios that we talked about the
Multiverse gets destroyed there's really
only kind of one Universe left at the
end they eventually defeat Kang and then
they have to try to somehow restore the
Multiverse only they don't fully restore
it and the universe that is now our main
MCU universe is going to be different
and what that means and this could be
kind of cool depending on your view of
it is that we could have a new Iron Man
we could have a new Captain America we
could have a new Black Widow in fact
even some characters who already exist
could actually change into different
variants the Hulk might not be played by
Mark Ruffalo anymore it could be a
different war machine because why not
they've already basically did that with
Secret Wars I'm sure you get the point
by now basically anything is kind of
possible in a new universe that would be
created but it gives us the opportunity
to have some of these majorly famous
characters come back that everybody has
known and loved over the past 10 plus
years and if they are going to do a
reboot this is honestly the best way to
do it a soft reboot that way Robert
Downey Jr's Iron Man still existed that
way Chris evans's Captain America still
existed everything from the past of the
MCU its history still happened but
technically it would have happened in a
different universe and the universe that
would continue past Avengers Secret Wars
would be the main Universe however it
would be different and another reason
that Marvel Studios could really want to
do this is the inclusion now of the
mutants and the X-Men a lot of people
have asked the question well if the
mutants are coming have they existed in
our universe this entire time and if
they have well why haven't we really
heard of them yet well one reason could
be because they're not actually in our
universe yet yes we do know that they
have kind of started to establish that
some people might have mutations like
Kamala Khan and the MCU but we haven't
seen any actual X-Men it doesn't seem
like the X-Men team is formed however we
do know that secret War is going to
bring in the X-Men from other universes
when incursions start to happen and
teams and universes start to collide and
interlap with each other we're gonna see
some of the original Fox X-Men and we'll
probably see some X-Men that we've never
seen before that are simply going to be
variants from other universes for
example Channing Tatum's Gambit we know
that he's gonna be in Deadpool 3 so he
could show up in secret Wars as well so
the X-Men team is going to be
established but we're gonna get our own
X-Men team in dmcu obviously starting in
Phase seven and it would make sense if
this new universe that has been created
from the events of Secret Wars that is
now going to be our main Universe has
changed a little bit and mutants are now
a little bit more prominent it's a great
segue for Marvel Studios to go into the
mutant Saga because again they
essentially get to do a reboot without
having to do one a soft reboot we keep
the old events for not erasing those but
we're going forward in a different
timeline which again opens up the door
for a new Iron Man for new Captain
America Etc and this is actually a
problem that Marvel City videos is kind
of facing right now a lot of fans have
been kind of unsatisfied with the new
characters that have been introduced
into the MCU because we were with Iron
Man for so long Captain America for so
long the original Avengers we were with
them for 10 plus years and yes we have
grown to love the characters because of
the actors who play them but people
still do also love the characters and
people would love to see another Iron
Man in the MCU but that cannot happen
unless one somebody else takes up the
mantle which kind of isn't the same I
really love Falcon Sam Wilson and I love
the fact that he's Captain America now
but we know it's not the same Captain
America well a reset a soft reboot would
give us the opportunity to have a Steve
Rogers Captain America in the MCU again
a Tony Stark Iron Man in the MCU again
so it could be a pretty good move by
Marvel to actually go this way with a
soft reboot to where Secret Wars makes
the universe going forward different
than the one that's been in the past and
they're not gonna just start off with a
new Iron Man they're gonna really focus
on the Fantastic Four and the X-Men
there's a ton of X-Men to introduce and
there are a ton of Fantastic Four
stories they can tell they can go years
without reintroducing the original
Avengers characters from the MCU like
Iron Man and Captain America and the
Hulk and this will make the MCU fresh
again it's going to be completely new
different characters with completely new
stories that we've never seen before and
then we can start to include some old
but new characters like Iron Man and the
Gang we knew Marvel Studios was thinking
about doing this but according to that
recent report it looks like they kind of
are leaning more towards the side of
doing it doing a soft reboot and it's a
risk it could definitely work but it
might also not so let us know what you
think about it down below in the
comments do you think this would be a
good idea or not and if so how do you
think they should go about doing it let
us know all of your thoughts and
theories about this in the comments down
below if you want to stay up to date on
everything regarding the MCU be sure to
subscribe to the channel and also DC as
well don't forget to like the video
please and of course you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf